[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend den allen wir müssen
beginnen mit Berichten heute abend nach
denen es Explosionen in Polen gab dabei
sind zwei Menschen getötet worden es
gibt Medienberichte die sagen Grund sein
russische Raketen die in Polen
eingeschlagen sind diese Berichte
berufen sich unter anderem auf
Geheimdienstinformationen aus den USA
aber auch der nationale Sicherheitsrat
in Polen ist zu einer Sondersitzung
einberufen worden
es geht um ein Dorf in unmittelbarer
Nähe zur Grenze zur Ukraine
das hier ist ein erstes Bild von dort
das auf Twitter kursiert auf die Ukraine
selbst gab es heute wieder massive
russische Luftangriffe eine ganze Welle
von russischen Raketen zielte vor allem
wieder auf die Energieversorgung des
Landes auch Wohngebäude in Kiew wurden
getroffen die Ukraine meldet ein
Todesopfer in vielen Städten der Ukraine
fällt der Strom aus und auch das
Nachbarland Republik Moldau
Beitrittskandidat in die EU meldet
massive Stromausfälle
wir bringen unsere Korrespondentin und
Korrespondenten mit dazu zunächst nach
Warschau zu Natalie Steger guten Abend
Natalie der nationale Sicherheitsrat
tagt gerade in Warschau was wissen wir
aktuell mit Sicherheit was passiert ist
mit Sicherheit wissen wir es noch nicht
weil er in der Tat noch tagt dieser
nationale Sicherheitsrat es gibt keine
offiziellen Bestätigung aber er ist sehr
eilig einberufen worden vom
Ministerpräsidenten moraviewski
Absprache mit Präsident duda und es
deutet alles auf eine Krisensituation in
das Zitat ist man habe sich jetzt
zusammengesetzt im Zusammenhang mit
bestehenden Krisensituationen also ganz
klar mit der Situation der
Kriegssituation im Nachbarland es gibt
noch keine offiziellen Äußerungen das
habe ich bereits gesagt aber es sollen
eben diese Geschosse in diese Getreide
Trocknungsanlage bei primwort auf
eingeschlagen sein acht Kilometer neue
Luftlinie von der ukrainischen Grenze
entfernt und laut polnischer Feuerwehr
gibt es eben auch zwei Todesopfer laut
AP der Nachrichtenagentur seines
russischer Raketen gewesen ein
polnischer Radiosender Set der sehr gut
normalerweise informiert ist aber es ist
eben nur eine Quelle die wir haben sagt
höchstwahrscheinlich Überreste einer
Pakete die von ukrainischen
Streitkräften abgeschossen wurden noch
nichts offizielles aber das ist
natürlich genau das was man in Polen
befürchtet hat dass man da in
irgendeiner Weise mit hineingezogen
werden könnte und auch die baltischen
Staaten haben versichert werden werde
das prüfen und im Zweifel Polen zur
Seite stehen aber noch Tag der nationale
Sicherheitsrat und wir müssen sicherlich
die nächsten Stunden abwarten sehr viele
unterschiedliche Informationen im Moment
Natalie du bleibst noch bei uns bevor
wir nach Brüssel gehen ganz kurz das der
ukrainische Präsident sagt russische
Raketen hätten Polen getroffen das
US-Außenministerium wird so zitiert die
Berichte sein unglaublich
besorgniserregend Hintergründe sein aber
noch zu klären und Russland dementiert
es habe keine Angriffe gegenziele nahe
der polnisch-ukrainischen Grenze gegeben
die Berichte dieser aktuellen Berichte
aus Polen seien eine Zitat Provokation
um die Situation eskalieren zu lassen
dann fragen wir doch in Brüssel nach bei
Florian Neuhann Hauptquartier wie
verhält sich denn die NATO jetzt aktuell
in dieser Situation in dem heutigen
Abend noch sehr zurückhaltend und
vorsichtig ich habe vor wenigen Minuten
an erste Reaktion eines nato-offiziellen
erhalten ein dürrer Satz den ich kurz
vorlesen kann wir prüfen uns diese
Berichte und stimmen uns eng mit unseren
Verbündeten Polen ab und das ist genau
die Grundmelodie der ersten Statements
die wir auch aus anderen NATO
Delegationen hören etwa aus dem
britischen Außenministerium oder von
Staats- und Regierungschefs aus
Osteuropa am deutlichsten war da bisher
auf Twitter der tschechische
Premierminister Peter Fiala aktuell auch
EU-Ratspräsident der schrieb es wäre
sollten sich die Berichte hier
bewahrheiten eine weitere Eskalation von
Seiten Russlands und klar ist natürlich
sollte es einen Angriff ein bewussten
Angriff auf nato-gebiet gegeben haben
dann wäre dies die ultimative Eskalation
die dann eben diesen berühmten
Bündnisfall Artikel 5 der NATO nach sich
ziehen würde aber klar ist eben auch bis
es soweit kommt ist es noch ein weiter
Weg denn diesen Bündnisfall den müssten
alle signator Alliierten einstimmig
beschließen also der Bündnisfall spricht
hat ein Angriff auf einen nato-staat
wird als Angriff auf alle anderen
gewertet wie ist das denn wenn es sich
um einen Querschläger handelt wird das
dann automatisch auch als Angriff
subsumiert nein definitiv nicht
automatisch dieser Fall ist natürlich in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten
theoretisch immer wieder durchgespielt
worden nach allem was ich daraus weiß
wird man keinesfalls jetzt sofort sagen
dass es ein Bündnisfall im Gegenteil
gewichtige NATO-Staaten vor allem aus
dem Westen aus Westeuropa werden da sehr
zurückhaltend sein weil man eben diese
direkte Konfrontation diesen offenen
Krieg zwischen NATO und Russland auf
jeden Fall vermeiden will man wird jetzt
morgen ganz normal zusammentreten im Rat
der Botschafter der NATO und intensiv
beraten sicherlich auch diesen Angriff
verbal scharf verurteilen aber ich höre
eben auch aus dem NATO-Hauptquartier es
sei jetzt besonders wichtig einen kühlen
Kopf zu bewahren also kühler Kopf das
ist der Appell aus Brüssel von der NATO
Florian herzlichen Dank Nathalie Steger
auch herzlichen Dank an beide jetzt
gehen wir weiter nach Berlin zur Theo
Kolb und nahm Theo wie reagiert die
Bundesregierung aktuell
nun die Außenministerin bärburg hat
gerade reagiert auf Englisch und gesagt
dass ihre Gedanken in Polen sind bei
unserem engen Verbündeten und Nachbarn
andere offizielle Reaktionen gibt es
bisher nicht der Kanzler ist ja noch in
Bali auf dem G20-Gipfel und die
polnischen Ansprechpartner für Berlin
sind in der eben erwähnten
sicherheitssitzung es gibt mehrere
Szenarien die auch hier erwähnt werden
entweder eine verirrte russische Rakete
oder ein absichtlicher Beschuss
polnischen Territoriums um die westliche
Reaktion zu testen oder es könnte auch
eine fehlgeleitete ukrainische
abwehrrakete sein oder Teile davon
Berlin geht jedenfalls davon aus dass
man das zügig Wissen wird möglicherweise
dann eben morgen eine Sitzung bei der
NATO hat die zentrale Frage aber dürfte
sein und die ist ja eben schon
angesprochen worden ist das ein Artikel
5 nato-fall und daran scheint hier
niemand zu denken auch wenn es eine
russische Rakete war
herzlichen Dank wenn wir Näheres wissen
bringen wir es Ihnen natürlich sofort
auch noch während dieser Sendung Theo
Koll hat es gerade schon kurz
angesprochen währenddessen sind ja knapp
zwei Drittel der Weltbevölkerung und 4/5
der weltweiten Wirtschaftskraft aktuell
in einem Ferienparadies versammelt
G20-Gipfel auf Bali die indonesischen
Gastgeber greifen tief in die Gruppen
dynamische Trickkiste um die Welt auch
tatsächlich zusammenzubringen Folklore
Show inklusive und siehe da es tut sich
was wohl nie zuvor seit Beginn des
Krieges war Russland international so
isoliert auf offener diplomatischer
Bühne wie heute was das Land allerdings
nicht davon abhält seine Angriffe heute
auf die Ukraine zu stoppen
diese Art von Weltregierung als die sich
die G20 gerne sieht hat viel zu tun und
wird jetzt auch mitten in der Nacht
durch die Nachrichten aus Polen
natürlich aufgeschreckt aus Bali eine
gelinek
der indonesische Präsident meint es
ernst auf keinen Fall will Joko vidodo
dass der G20 Club auseinanderfällt schon
gar nicht unter seiner Präsidentschaft
auch deshalb steckt er alle
Gipfel-Teilnehmer zum galadina in
traditionelle Hemden vom Kanadier trido
bis hin zu Chinas Staatspräsidenten
shijin Ping vom neuen britischen
premiersunak bis hin zu Russlands lavrov
alle in Batik das soll zusammenschweißen
tatsächlich ist es dem indonesischen
Präsidenten gelungen den Club
einigermaßen zusammenzuhalten eine
gipfelerklärung scheint so gut wie
verabredet harte Kritik an Russlands
Angriff auf die Ukraine steht ebenso
drin wie das Russland anderer Meinung
ist am Morgen scheinen die
Mehrheitsverhältnisse so klar dass der
vorsichtige Indonesia in seiner
Eröffnungsrede fast Klartext spricht
ein wir müssen den Krieg beenden wenn
der Krieg nicht zu Ende geht kann sich
die Welt nicht weiterentwickeln
und dann lässt der volo Denise sprechen
zugeschaltet aus Kiew der fordert den
sofortigen Abzug aller russischen
Truppen aus seinem Land und die
Kontrolle der Ukraine über ihre Grenzen
die gipfelregie zeigt keine Reaktionen
im Saal aber die Stimmung muss eisig
gewesen sein viele Zuhörer nicken lavrov
zeigt keine Regung später aber wirft er
dem Westen vor die G20 politisiert und
die Mehrheitsverhältnisse verzerrt zu
haben
niemand außerdem Westen und seiner
Satelliten unterstützt die
anti-russischen Sanktionen in der Welt
die Länder der Dritten Welt rufen zu
einer friedlichen Lösung auf und
verstehen genau dass die Ukraine diesen
Prozess behindert
Entwicklungs- und Schwellenländer wie
Senegal Südafrika oder Argentinien
interessierte der ukraine-konflikt
bislang kaum doch der Krieg beginnt zu
stören wegen steigender Preise
Energieknappheit handelsprobleme und so
nimmt die Unterstützung für Russlands
Militäraktion eher ab mein Eindruck aus
vielen Gesprächen mit vielen der Länder
die sich bei der UN-Generalversammlung
enthalten haben ist nämlich dass viele
davon
innerlich überzeugt sind dass dies ein
ungerechter Krieg ist und ein
überflüssiger
für überflüssig hielt sich am Ende des
ersten gipfeltags auch sergejlav und
bestieg am Abend seine
Regierungsmaschine nach Moskau immer
noch im blauen batikhemd Souvenir eines
schwierigen Gipfels
wir bleiben bei dem was unsere Welt
bewegt seit dieses heute journal
begonnen hat sind wir wieder
750 Menschen mehr auf der Welt das ist
das Tempo mit dem wir heute bei 8
Milliarden Menschen auf der Erde
angekommen sind dem einzigen Planeten
den wir haben die UNO hat das
ausgerechnet und zwar so von der ersten
Milliarde dauerte es über 120 Jahre bis
sich 1927 die Zahl der Menschen auf der
Erde verdoppelt hatte
zwei Milliarden hätten wir hier nicht
untergebracht wir symbolisieren sie also
durch 20 Menschen hier im Studio bis
1960 wurden es dann bereits drei
Milliarden Menschen also 30 hier bei uns
und dann ging es steil nach oben bis zu
den 8 Milliarden jetzt
das Wachstum verteilt sich auf die
Kontinente ganz unterschiedlich deutlich
mehr als die Hälfte der Menschheit lebt
heute in Asien und dort ist Indien dem
weltweit bevölkerungsreichsten Land
China mittlerweile dicht auf den Fersen
Norman Odenthal berichtet
geboren in Delhi das Leben beginnt mit
Gebrüll mit einem Gähnen oder einem
gesunden Schlaf Alltag auf der
Geburtsstation Geschwister werden
entdeckt Familien wachsen ich habe schon
eine Tochter und jetzt auch einen Sohn
die Ärztin sagte sollten nicht mehr als
die zwei bekommen mein Mann ist
Bauarbeiter es wäre schwer für mehr
Kinder zu sorgen
guten Morgen liebe Patientinnen grüßt
sie mal schauhahn und kommt dann schnell
zur Sache sie könnte Windeln verteilen
oder anderes Nützliches für Mütter und
Neugeborene aber sie hat Kondome hier
nimm erstmal die zur Verhütung in ein
paar Wochen hast du dich von der Geburt
erholt dann kommst du wieder und wir
sprechen über Familienplanung und die
richtige Methode Methoden gibt es viele
das Ziel ist immer gleich keine weiteren
Kinder
wir haben Möglichkeiten Nachwuchs zu
kontrollieren die sollten wir nutzen ich
denke es ist eine Frage der Bildung
besser Gebildete planen eine Familie
sorgfältiger ungebildete brauchen
Beratung damit Sie verstehen
Familienplanung ist eine gute Sache
bislang wächst Indien eher ohne Plan in
Kürze wird es das bevölkerungsreichste
Land der Welt sein vor China 1,4
Milliarden in davon 8 Milliarden
Erdenbürgern insgesamt
der riesige demografische Zuwachs wurde
lange als ökonomischer Vorteil
betrachtet aber es hat sich
herausgestellt dass es eine ökonomische
Belastung ist von den zahlreichen jungen
Leuten in Indien bleiben viele
arbeitslos und chancenlos
Bildung für so viele wie soll das gehen
Nahrung Wasser Energie für so viele
woher soll es kommen wie den Verkehr
bändigen wohin mit dem Müll fragen über
Fragen
babita hat zwei Kinder mehr werden es
nicht heute findet die Familienplanung
ihr Ende
es ist kostenlos die Regierung bezahlt
deshalb bin ich hier
das ist babitas Gang zur Sterilisation
ein kurzer Eingriff eine gute halbe
Stunde aber keine Kleinigkeit die
riesigen hat sie in Kauf genommen ihre
freie Entscheidung wohl kaum Ehemann
Ravi für das Wort
sie ist meine Frau ich habe sie
sterilisieren lassen ich habe zwei Söhne
und unser Geld reicht nur für zwei denn
sie sollen eine gute Bildung bekommen
die Entscheidung fällt Ravi leichter
denn er hat wonach so viele in der
Streben Söhne
in der Gesellschaft muss ankommen dass
eine Tochter genauso wertvoll ist wie
ein Sohn das muss in die Köpfe damit die
Leute nicht wie verrückt Nachwuchs
produzieren bis sie endlich den Sohn den
Stammhalter haben mit ein zwei Kindern
sollen sie zufrieden sein selbst wenn es
zwei Töchter sind
Indiens Erfahrung ist die Erfahrung der
ganzen Welt Nachwuchs ist toll aber auch
eine Herausforderung und sie wird mit
jedem Kind größer
[Musik]
ist Wissenschaftler am Bundesinstitut
für Bevölkerungsforschung in gewisser
Weise kann man also sagen erzählt sehr
professionell sein Leben lang uns
Menschen dass wir hat Schnee schönen
guten Abend
guten Abend ich nehme an sie sind jetzt
nicht besonders überrascht über diese
Zahl heute über 8 Milliarden Menschen
mich würde interessieren ist das jetzt
eine sehr gute oder eine schlechte
Nachricht für Sie die 8 Milliarden
kommen tatsächlich nicht überraschend
generell ist das Wachstum auf 8
Milliarden eine gute Nachricht
Ursache für das bildbevölkerungswachstum
ist eine Rückgang der Sterblichkeit mehr
Kinder überleben mehr Erwachsene
erreichen ein höheres Alter die
Lebenserwartung insgesamt steigt das ist
eine gute Botschaft
und wenn sie jetzt mal in ihre Forschung
und gucken wird das jetzt immer so
weitergehen mit der
Bevölkerungsentwicklung oder was
erwarten sie da nach der Prognose der
Vereinten Nationen ist in den 2080er
Jahren mit einem Maximum der
Weltbevölkerung etwa bei 10,4 Milliarden
Menschen zu rechnen also 10,4 Milliarden
und ab dann dann stagniert die
Bevölkerung oder geht sogar zurück
danach wird die Bevölkerung leicht
zurückgehen ist denn das sicher ist das
in Stein gemeißelt wissen wir das jetzt
schon so genau sie reden von 2018 dass
er noch ein paar Jahrzehnte hin die
Prognosen sind für die nächsten
Jahrzehnte relativ sicher denn die
Menschen die dann leben werden sind
heute bereits geboren Einfluss nehmen
auf die Bevölkerungsentwicklung wird für
die nächsten Jahrzehnte kaum möglich
sein denn die
weltbevölkerungsentwicklung hängt vom
Geburtenniveau und der Altersstruktur in
den Ländern ab in denen derzeit noch
sehr viele Kinder bekommen in der
Altersstruktur dieser Länder ist das
künftige Bevölkerungswachstum bereits
heute festgelegt jetzt gibt es ja Leute
die sagen auch wir brauchen weniger
Menschen auf dieser Welt die haben
natürlich gut reden weil sie selbst
schon auf der Welt sind
lässt sich denn eine Zahl festmachen wie
viel wie viel Menschen dieser Planet
verträgt oder hängt das am Ende gar
nicht an einer Zahl
die Tragfähigkeit der Erde hängt nicht
in erster Linie an der Zahl der
Bevölkerung sie hängt daran wie wir
konsumieren und tatsächlich ist die
tragfähigkeitsgrenze der Erde bereits
seit den 1970er Jahren überschritten
derzeit brauchen wir das Äquivalent von
1,7 Erden um unseren Bedarf global
nachhaltig zu decken und was müssen wir
jetzt ändern damit diese Welt eine
lebenswerte für alle wird
Bevölkerungswachstum und auch der hohe
Konsum in den Industrieländern muss von
dem Einfluss auf den auf den
ökologischen Fußabdruck entkoppelt
werden wie das gelingen kann dafür gibt
es viele einzelne Ideen und Ansätze ob
das in der Summe reichen wird wird die
Zukunft sein Franks wertschnee war das
vom Bundesinstitut für
Bevölkerungsforschung her es wird schon
herzlichen Dank herzlichen Dank
der Appell eines Wissenschaftlers das
Gespräch einmal kurz vor der Sendung
aufgezeichnet dort wo die Bevölkerung am
schnellsten wächst sind auch die
Herausforderungen schon jetzt am größten
am Beispiel Irak zeigen sich dramatische
Bilder immer mehr Menschen dort heißt
immer mehr Wasserverbrauch und dazu
kommt die Klimakrise der Irak ist eines
der fünf am schlimmsten betroffenen
Länder weltweit aus einer Region in der
man mittlerweile jeden grünen Fleck
suchen muss berichtet gollinea
irgendwann fanden sie keine Gräser keine
Sträucher mehr kein Laub das
schattenspendet in diesem Sommer waren
irakskopfgazellen die ersten Opfer der
Dürre die das Land seit drei Jahren
erfasst hat
dutzende veränderten
in unmittelbarer Nähe der Gazellen einer
der viele nun ausgetrockneten Seen des
Irak der zaubersee war ein Wahrzeichen
des Landes der Hydrologe serhaner
brachte seine Studenten oft hierher ans
Wassers ist vor allem eine Folge des
Klimawandels im Irak das Ausbleiben des
Regens die vermehrte Verdunstung und
dazu kommt noch das in der Gegend
zuletzt mehr als 2000 Brunnen gebohrt
wurden
für die Landwirtschaft doch das half
nichts die Hälfte seines agrarlandes hat
der Irak dieses Jahr an die Wüste
verloren
es gab Tage erzählen sie hier der
erreichten die Temperaturen
unerträgliche 55 Grad im Südirak haben
tausende Bauern ihre Dörfer verlassen
sie sehen es das Land ist verödet die
Erde ist voller Salz und wir sind arm
geworden wir wollen weg von hier aber
niemand heißt uns woanders willkommen
was tun wenn nichts mehr wächst
die legendären Palmen des südiraks sind
nur noch eine Erinnerung
an der Grenze zwischen Irak und Iran
hassandra Liel von der Universität Basra
erklärt wie der Nachbar Iran etliche
Flüsse in eigenes Territorium umgeleitet
hat und wie viele Dämme er gebaut hat
seinerseits eine Reaktion auf den
Klimawandel im Irak kommt dadurch fast
kein Süßwasser mehr an
in deiner Werner wenn sie hier vor 40
Jahren ein Bild von oben aufgenommen
hätten es wäre dunkelgrün gewesen hier
wuchsen alle Arten von Palmen mit teuren
einzigartigen Datteln und Gärten voller
Zitrusfrüchte
im Frühsommer das Wasser im Tigris ging
so weit zurück dass Menschen im Fluss
stehen konnten
die Stadt erstickte an Sandstürmen es
werden von Jahr zu Jahr näher haben
Klimaforscher ausgerechnet
stromabwärts am Persischen Golf hier
kommt immer weniger Süßwasser von Iraks
Flüssen an währenddessen treibt immer
mehr Salzwasser ins Land hinein
ich erwarte dass der Meeresspiegel
weiter steigt durch den Klimawandel und
das Land hier ist nicht hoch genug
in weniger als 30 Jahren könnten Teile
des südiraks überflutet werden vom Meer
ja Bilder die aufrütteln sollten vom
Irak jetzt ins Nachbarland Iran in dem
die heftigen Proteste gegen das Regime
der Mullahs 9 Zulauf bekommen Hanna ja
auch heute gab es wieder landesweite
Demonstrationen gegen das iranische
Regime und außerdem wurde zu Streiks
aufgerufen zahlreiche Geschäfte bieben
geschlossen wie hier auf dem Basar in
Teheran aber sollten die heutigen
Proteste auch an den sogenannten
blutigen November 2019 erinnern damals
schlug die iranische Führung die
Demonstrationen gegen steigende
Benzinpreise gewaltsam nieder hunderte
protestierende wurden getötet
Justizminister Buschmann und
Außenministerin baerbock haben zu einer
weltweiten Abschaffung der Todesstrafe
aufgerufen im vergangenen Jahr seien
erstmals seit langem wieder mehr
Todesurteile vollstreckt worden erklärte
Buschmann beim Weltkongress gegen die
Todesstrafe in Berlin und verwies
außerdem auf die Gefahr von Justiz
Irrtümern wer Box sagte dass die
Todesstrafe noch in mehr als 50 Staaten
vollzogen werde und autoritäre Regime
wie Iran sie nutzen würden um
Oppositionelle zu unterdrücken
rund 30 Jahre nach den Rechtsextremen
Brandanschlägen in
schleswig-holsteinischen Mölln hat sich
Bundespräsident Steinmeier mit
Hinterbliebenen des Attentats zu
Gesprächen getroffen in der Nacht vom 22
auf den 23 November 1992 steckten zwei
Neonazis die Wohnhäuser türkischer
Familien in Brand drei Menschen starben
neun wurden schwer verletzt die Täter
wurden unter anderem wegen Mordes
verurteilt
in China ist es wegen der strengen
corona-maßnahmen erneut zu
Ausschreitungen gekommen
Textilarbeiter Rissen in der
südchinesischen
Millionenmetropole guangjou Absperrungen
nieder dort Medienberichten kamen sie
aus der Quarantäne zurück durften aber
wegen der corona-beschränkungen nicht in
ihre Wohnungen seit Wochen wächst in
China der Unmut über die harte
nullkovic-politik
das heute journal Update zeigt nachher
dazu einen ausführlichen Film unserer
Peking Korrespondentin die corona-regeln
in China führen zunehmend zu gewaltsamen
Protesten die corona-regeln bei uns
führen zunehmend zu Stirnrunzeln denn
kaum noch jemandem ist wirklich klar
welche Regeln eigentlich wo gelten und
ob es überhaupt noch Regeln braucht
andere europäische Länder haben den
Schritt längst gemacht dort muss ich
auch wer Corona hat nicht mehr
automatisch selbst isolieren vier
Bundesländer bei uns wollen das auch
einführen andere überlegen noch andere
lehnen das strikt ab es droht wie Banner
schon traditionell beim Thema Corona ein
föderaler Flickenteppich Britta
Spiekermann mit mehr
Gedränge auf dem deutschen
Krankenhaustag in Düsseldorf Masken
sieht man hier selten bis gar nicht
immerhin auch viele Ärzte und Ärzte sind
gekommen ist Corona schon Geschichte ob
man jetzt schon allgemein erklären kann
dass die Pandemie zu Ende ist das ist
eine Frage die die Politik gemeinsam mit
den Fachbehörden entscheiden muss manche
Länder in Europa haben diese
Entscheidung schon getroffen in
Deutschland steht sie auf jeden Fall an
und damit auch Entscheidungen über
Regeln wie die isolationspflicht weniger
Pflicht mehr Gebot sagt der
Bundesärztekammer Präsident das sei
medizinisch vertretbar wir haben keine
isolationspflicht mehr in Großbritannien
Portugal Spanien Dänemark Österreich
Schweiz Frankreich Schweden um mal nur
die zu nennen und insofern glaube ich
dass wenn und dort herrschen der
ähnliche Verhältnisse über uns also ich
glaube man muss wegkommen noch einmal
von dem Umgang mit der Pandemie rein
infektionsschutzgesichtspunkten es
bewegt sich etwas Baden-Württemberg
Bayern Hessen und Schleswig-Holstein
gehen eigene Wege schaffen die
isolationspflicht ab
Schleswig-Holsteins Ministerpräsident
will noch mehr die maskenpflicht soll
fallen es ist niemand gezwungen auf eine
Maske zu verzichten das heißt man kann
ja im ÖPNV oder in größeren Menschen ab
Ansammlung wenn man sich selbst schützen
möchte auch eine Maske tragen aber für
staatliche Anordnung für staatliche
Maßnahmen er ist in dieser Pfanne Phase
der Pandemie gibt es keine Begründung
mehr dafür Daniel Günther führt eine
hohe Impfquote und mildere Verläufe ins
Feld und versteht Karl Lauterbach nicht
der die Lage vollkommen anders
einschätzt es gibt auch keinen
medizinischen Grund hier ist auf
isolationspflicht zu verzichten wir
haben derzeit etwa 1000 Todesfälle durch
Kurve pro Woche
gar nicht ob die Menschen mit Kurve
verstorben sind oder wegen Corvette
verstorben sind das ist eine Arbeit
offene Frage neben der unterschiedlichen
Auslegung der Todeszahlen gibt es auch
keine einheitliche wissenschaftliche
Meinung zur isolationspflicht
Grundrechtseingriffe müssen gut
begründet sein und vor dem Hintergrund
ist es eben nachvollziehbar dass der
alte Grundsatz wir krank ist bleibt zu
Hause vollkommen ausreichend ist um
durch die nächsten Wochen und Monate zu
kommen wenn uns was dran liegt die
Wellen möglichst flach zu halten sollten
wir alle Möglichkeiten nutzen um das
Infektionsgeschehen eben kontrollieren
zu können und dazu gehört definitiv die
isolationspflicht
verantwortungslos sei die Abkehr von der
isolationspflicht sagt Minister
Lauterbach vier Bundesländer sehen das
anders auch weite Teile der Ärzteschaft
sie setzen auf das Prinzip
Eigenverantwortung
ja ich sage mal voraus das Thema bleibt
uns noch erhalten genauso wie das Thema
jetzt bei dir Hannah
zur Energieversorgung in
Deutschland der erdgaspeicher hat die
100% Marke erreicht und außerdem wurde
das erste Terminal für flüssig Erdgas
eingeweiht und zwar in Wilhelmshaven
Frank Bethmann das klingt erstmal nach
positiven Nachrichten für alle Gaskunden
den gerade ja die Preiserhöhungen ins
Haus flattern aber wird das die Lage
überhaupt spürbar entspannen im
Portemonnaie wird man das erstmal nicht
spüren die aktuelle kurzfristige
Entspannung hat wenig Einfluss auf die
Verbraucherpreise dafür müssten die
Gaspreise schon über mehrere Monate
deutlich sinken grundsätzlich aber
stehen die Zeichen zumindest
vorübergehend auf Entspannung volle
Speicher und nun wird auch konkreter
dass die erdgasimporte per Schiff einen
wachsenden Beitrag zur Versorgungslage
beitragen werden in Wilhelmshaven also
steht das erste deutsche
flüssiggasterminal kurz vor seiner
Fertigstellung weitere Hafenanlagen in
Brunsbüttel Stade und Lubmin werden
hinzukommen die beiden ersten
schwimmenden Terminals die fertig werden
Wilhelmshaven und Brunsbüttel sollen von
Januar bis März Milliarden Kubikmeter
Gas ins deutsche Netz liefern zum
Vergleich im Jahr 2021 bezog Deutschland
aus Russland von Januar bis März 15
Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas noch klaffte
also eine Versorgungslücke doch mit den
zusätzlich geplanten Terminals könnte es
gelingen so formulierte ist
Niedersachsens Landesvater weil heute
Russland komplett zu ersetzen was
allerdings umgehend den
landesenergieminister Meyer von den
Grünen auf dem Plan rief die Verwendung
von Flüssiggas sollte doch bitte nur
eine Übergangslösung sein verbunden mit
der Forderung die Terminals später auch
für grünen Wasserstoff zu nutzen vielen
Dank Frank für deine Einschätzungen
es ist die Generalprobe für die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft vor Beginn der
Weltmeisterschaft in Katar morgen
bestreitet sie ihr letztes Testspiel
gegen den Oman auf Antonio Rüdiger und
Thomas Müller muss Trainer Hansi flickt
dabei verzichten beide sind angeschlagen
Blick betonte nach dem Abschlusstraining
heute in Maskat es gehe nun erst einmal
darum alle auf das gleiche Niveau zu
bringen nächste Woche Mittwoch steht
dann der gruppenauftakt gegen Japan an
so die Situation rund um die Explosionen
heute Abend in Polen ist weiter unklar
es gibt eine neue Eilmeldung vom
Regierungssprecher in Polen er sagt wir
erhöhen jetzt die Alarmbereitschaft von
Militäreinheiten und gerade eben kommen
noch zwei weitere Eilmeldungen rein die
da sagt er wir werden jetzt überprüfen
ob wir den nato-artikel 4 da geht es
also um Konsultationen der verschiedenen
Nato-Partner aktivieren werden sobald
neues gibt hält sie natürlich unser
Online-Angebot ZDF heute jederzeit auf
dem aktuellen Stand und von uns allen
hier auch hinter der Kamera für heute
erstmal danke für Ihr Interesse und
unser heute journal Update gibt es gegen
0 Uhr mit Christopher wermann angenehmen
Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ein umfangreiches
hoch über Skandinavien blockiert derzeit
den Weg der tiefste von Westen
herankommen aber nach Norden hin
ausweichen müssen dazu kommt kühle Luft
aus dem Osten und sie sehen auch hier
warme Luft die uns erreicht und diese
Luftmassengrenze die etabliert sich über
Deutschland so gibt es viele Wolken und
Regen und bereits in der kommenden Nacht
von Westen her ja und da regnet es
durchaus auch mal kräftiger nach Osten
hin ist es trocken an der Donau da
bildet sich wieder Nebel dort gehen die
Temperaturen zurück auf ein Grad und am
mildesten noch am Niederrhein mit 10
Grad morgen im Tagesverlauf wandern die
Wolken weiter nach Osten und dann bleibt
diese
Luftmassengrenze quasi hängen und es
regnet zeitweise kräftig ganz im Westen
sind einzelne shower dabei aber auch
Auflockerungen mit Sonnenschein und ganz
nach Nordosten kommt diese
Luftmassengrenze nicht voran da bleibt
es ebenfalls relativ sonnig aber die
Temperaturen haben einen großen
Unterschied hier sieben bis acht Grad
nach Westen in 15 Grad und auch am
Oberrhein um die 14 Grad die nächsten
Tage wir haben es weiterhin mit Regen zu
tun und die Luftmassengrenze bleibt
unterhalten dazu Sturm an der Nordsee
bei 4 bis 16 Grad am Freitag vor allem
im Osten Temperaturen bei 1 Grad einige
Schneeflocken dabei und Samstag sogar
nur 0 Grad damit ein schöner Abend